happy Thursday reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey John got back
from a trip you'd arrived here I don't
know like to a ever so that I will go up
at six with a migraine so I said let's
go away now we're here men in black
International the movie we've all been
asking for been waiting for finally here
John how was your trip I haven't caught
up with you one millisecond it was good
it was great to catch up with everybody
yeah good to you know do what we have do
you did not travel internationally for
transition listen I wanted to give an
obligatory shout out to everyone who's
been following us in the Stardust at
over there we do thirty second reaction
reviews for any film TV show or trailer
every once in a while there micro
sketches we post daily so loved it
who follow us there because I love
Stardust woo and so is John Bailey I
leave for Colorado in a few hours so
there's gonna be real lack of editing in
this review part let's get into it Liam
Neeson
oh here we go
[Music]
spider-verse
yeah got the same Bobby
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
advertising
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
like hella you know what I wish this
trailer gave me really dawned on me
about 2 minutes and 20 seconds into this
trip I wish this trailer was giving me
the the chemistry and the dynamic duo of
these two yeah it's like I know this
Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson can act
together they were a great Authority
rock whatever they bounce off one
another I'm sure it'll be great and like
their chemistry I'm talking about show
me that cuz cuz I'm like this all just
looks like men in black retread
territory really dated gadgets in like a
lot of it seems to be ODS and callbacks
and very similar setups and like I
remember this I met him black remember
this two men in black in that way this
trailer feels like it's very much
feeling itself like it thinks it's
really cool just cuz it's doing okay
yeah and I mean yeah I mean there's a
certain amount of that that I would
probably want and appreciate in a men
and black reboot of sorts but I yeah I
wanted something maybe a little bit more
distinct than just like oh cool you're
you're doing stuff I recognized and
you're like repeating the monologue from
the first one alright I was very much
flashing back to Ghostbusters 2 which
maybe is just cuz it's Chris Hemsworth
at a desk this feels very much like it
wants me to think about that energy of
his character and that goes Buster's
movie I think too has a similar quality
where it is a bit sillier than
Ghostbusters as I remember goes like
Ghostbusters has its aney qualities but
there's enough like you said the center
to make the stakes feel kind of gripping
and real that's what I hope the movie
has
I'm just not seeing I mean I care to
hear the comments of like I can't
believe you laughed and like the Hellboy
trailer but you don't like this for me
I'm like well at least the Hellboy
trailer is doing a total like 180 you
know this I'm like what are they doing
commit something like why is this a new
director but it looks like barry
sonnenfeld directed like kind of a clips
medley of just all the previous his F
gary Gray is directing this one not very
song felt interesting I mean I've Barry
gray hey he's got style
the guy yeah the guy also knows how to
bring a lot of energy you mean fate of
the Furious I'm not exactly a big fan of
that movie but I think he really does
deliver on providing a really kinetic
film
yeah and Straight Outta Compton has a
lot of cool style behind the camera
throughout that whole movie that's the
kind of grit out one of a minimum yeah
well you know it's a cheeky rap song
though to tell us that we're going to
London yeah I guess that now that I'm
picking up from is that Tessa Thompson's
agent M is like just an awesome student
right yeah
really like the bookworm really smart
really psyched to show up and do a great
job probably show that she knows every
technicality about each Canadian there's
Chris Hemsworth who's like the badass
but you know it's just like nonchalant
yeah to sleep at word yeah you got Liam
Neeson saying funny stuff is the I don't
know because she's gonna be kind of
disappointed at first by their matchup
when she realizes that his greatness is
unorthodox but then they will learn
appreciate each other's you know unique
strengths by the end of the movie I'm
not sure if I just woke up and there's a
men in black trailer alright this
trailer just like there's something
feels weird ly paced about it I guess I
don't mind it it just it feels weird Lee
pace to me well yeah cuz it's a very
rapid trailer at least that was the
flavor it left to me was I kind of wish
that since we're reintroducing men and
black you know and we're kind of up to
you know we're updating it I wish they
might have done something that was a
little more teaser at least at the
beginning that maybe breathed a little
bit more or took like a specific moment
or
motif to reintroduce the world instead
of like the energy of this just went
yeah you changed it's like you know no
time as fast it's the last one they're
saying stuff like the world is expanding
and all those you know cool things you
say would you look what you soft reboot
something it doesn't look like it that's
why I think that would really help sell
this film especially if you have a
two-minute it's 2 minute 45 seconds
trailer I think if you have a 245 second
trailer you got a hone in on who your
two new characters are yeah because this
is soft reboot obviously cuz they had
those pictures to show you you know not
that things Sonny likes to do with their
things they go it's a so exist we might
be able to bring this trailer was
missing an element for me of like the
first men in black movie is like fun and
whimsical and you know sci-fi and all
that but it takes itself just seriously
enough whereas I can't tell what they
feel real yeah definitely where it's
like when they're trying to save the
world
oh god yeah easy yeah the thing I didn't
get from this trailer is exactly what
the stakes could be and how it doesn't I
don't know this is a very fun trailer
that seems like it's very pitched
towards look how fun there's gonna be
Chris having a great time so those tend
Thompson yeah yeah which is a lot of
trailers nowadays yeah which isn't bad
but I'm like okay but I want to get the
sense for what the actual movies gonna
feel and especially what their chemistry
and their like just because people have
great chemistry in one movie doesn't
always mean they're gonna have great
chemistry in the next movie I doubt they
won't but let's face it that the big
charm of the men in black movies beyond
its world and its crazy universe had
always been the dynamic duo of agent J&K
yeah yeah and that we discovered this
trailer really needed to sell me on that
and instead of just as meta my classic
pediments minute block with yeah
and I think I'm a Tom emma thompson is
uh she takes over for Zetas men in black
3 so I think that's reconnection here
right that's cool yeah one you know I'm
sure this is uh I'm sure I'm sure at the
end of the day I'll walk out just being
like that's why I want I want this to be
like I'm really excited that men in
black is coming back and I just want
them to nail it because you know we
remember how disappointed everybody was
when that franchise wasn't great yeah
that's so much potential well what do
you think of men in black international
have you guys seen the men in black
International International trade that's
what I thought this actually instead of
it topped I was like what is way for the
usj totally different there's probably
gonna be a lot less dialogue I see
totally misread that anyway you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell download and
false in the start us out today people
yeah